ich habe jetzt hier meine fertige Soße
die ist auch schon abgeschmeckt es fehlt
kein Salz perfekt
[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen in Sallys Welt
heute gibt es ein leckeres Gericht aus
dem Ofen nämlich Lachs auf toskanische
Art mit Nudeln ist für uns ein
komplettes Gericht da ich eben Pasta
dazu serviere ihr könnt das ganze aber
auch gerne Low Carb zubereiten und
Gemüse dazu servieren ganz wie ihr
möchtet ich habe ja Lachs immer im
Tiefkühlfach ich habe das immer da weil
wir es eigentlich tatsächlich ganz gerne
essen ich bin nicht so der Mega Fisch
Fan aber Lachs finde ich mega und wenn
wir frischen Fisch haben irgendwo am
Meer sind dann esse ich Fisch auch gerne
aber ansonsten nicht so dafür nehme ich
etwas Olivenöl eine Zwiebel und
Knoblauchzehe 100 Gramm babyspinat ein
paar Tomaten ich habe jetzt hier noch
Cocktailtomaten 200 Gramm Gemüsebrühe
etwas Sahne Salz und Pfeffer getrocknete
Tomaten 600 Gramm Lachs ich habe noch
ein paar Nudeln und Basilikum perfekt
also der Lachs ist jetzt noch gefroren
und ich zeige euch jetzt mal was weil
ich selber als ich es gesehen habe
einfach so verblüfft war und zwar
habe ich von GEFU so ein auftaubbrett
bekommen das sind Schneidebrett auf der
Seite könnt ihr ganz normal schneiden
jetzt noch so eine Reibe für Knoblauch
Ingwer zum Beispiel jetzt sogar ein
Messerschärfer und auf der Seite hier
ist die Seite zum auftauen und zwar hat
mir das der Rudolf Inhaber von gefo mit
einem Eiswürfel gezeigt und ich konnte
meinen Augen nicht glauben es war wie
als hätte ich einen Zeitraffer so in
echt einfach da liegen er hat ein
Eiswürfel draufgelegt und das Brett das
entzieht einfach allen Lebensmitteln
sofort diese Kälte und dadurch tauen
Lebensmittel mega schnell auf ihr
braucht keine Mikrowelle mehr und ihr
braucht nicht ewig warten und es war
einfach der Hammer und ich habe mir
gedacht du musst das einfach live sehen
das war Wahnsinn
drauf ich zeige es euch dann gleich ich
lege euch gleich auch noch ein Eiswürfel
drauf weil ich finde das muss man
einfach mal gesehen haben jedenfalls
stelle ich den Lachs kurz zur Seite
damit er eben Auftauen kann
ich muss das jetzt der Jutta zeigen
Jutta komme mal und zwar ist es ein
auftaubrett
das sind so Rillen drin das sind Saft
drin damit eben die Flüssigkeit
aufgefangen wird hier ist ein
Messerschärfer das ist ein normales
Schneidebrett und hier zum Reiben von
Ingwer und
Knoblauch und es rutscht auch nicht auf
der Arbeitsfläche weil rund um Silikon
jetzt zeige ich das mal mit dem
Eiswürfel jetzt bin ich gespannt ich war
nämlich das hat echt aussehen wie ein
echter Zeitraffer
tatsächlich guck mal und zwar ich meine
mit einem Eiswürfel klar der schmilzt
jetzt sofort weg weiß halt nur einer ist
wenn man jetzt da Lachs drauf hat 600
Gramm geht's natürlich nicht ganz so
schnell aber trotzdem schneller als wenn
man es so Auftauen lässt man braucht
keine Mikrowelle und ich finde es
einfach krass dass der in Echtzeit
einfach wegschmilzt ich habe da keine
werbeplatte oder so drunter
okay
ich habe nämlich auch gedacht als der
Rudolf mir das gezeigt hat dachte ich es
sieht aus wie so ein echter Zeit darauf
war
und ich meine zum Vergleich ich habe
hier auch noch Eiswürfel und die
Schmelze halten nicht weg
fährt
was ja und wieso ist das jetzt weil hier
dazwischen einfach Material ist dass ich
ich nehme auch oft im Mai zum wenn ich
was abkühlen lassen will weil er Mai
auch die Temperatur annimmt und dann
schön verteilt aber hier geht's halt
noch schneller das ist halt schon krass
ich fand das so zum vorführt einfach so
cool also ein Auftritt ziemlich cool
gemacht
einfach schnell so eine Pfütze bildet
irgendwie Spiel wenn es heiß wird
also zwiebel und Knoblauchzehe schälen
und fein hacken
[Musik]
dann kann ich jetzt hier schon mal etwas
Olivenöl in meiner Pfanne erhitzen nehmt
jetzt einfach eine beschichtete Pfanne
dazu
da kommen die Zwiebel und Knoblauch
Würfel dazu muss er jetzt gar nicht so
hoch erhitzt werden
einfach für 23 Minuten anbraten
könnt ihr hier die cocktailtomaten
halbieren und ich gebe bei mir gleich
noch getrocknete Tomaten dazu weil die
einfach so einen guten Geschmack haben
ich weiß dass bei mir immer mal wieder
Menschen schreiben sie mögen keine
getrockneten Tomaten ich kann es ehrlich
gesagt nicht nachvollziehen vielleicht
schreibt ihr mir mal warum aber ich
finde die sind schön würzig die haben
mir ganz tolle Konsistenz sogar Murat
findet das ein toller Fleischersatz sind
also vielleicht könnt ihr euch da ja mal
ran trauen und oft ist er so wenn ihr
getrocknete Tomaten habt ihr einfach nur
trocken sind sind die halt richtig hart
wie Leder aber ihr könnt die ja auch in
Öl kaufen und in Öl eingelegt sind halt
richtig soft sind so richtige
softtomaten die sind echt gut
dann gebe ich jetzt hier den Spinat dazu
dann kommt jetzt noch die Gemüsebrühe
dazu
Tomaten kommen mit rein
dann etwas mit Salz und Pfeffer
abschmecken
dann die getrockneten Tomaten auch gerne
noch ein bisschen hacken
die kommen auch mit dazu
und dann könnt ihr das jetzt schon mit
der Sahne aufgießen
[Musik]
einmal kurz aufkochen lassen und dann
den Herd ausschalten
[Musik]
ich wollte eigentlich ein ofengericht
machen deswegen hatte ich eigentlich
auch schon die Ofenform hier könnt ihr
auch gerne machen indem ihr alle Zutaten
roh hier rein gibt und dann den Ofen
gebt das wäre so die einfachste
Möglichkeit aber ich wollte dann doch
ein bisschen Röstaromen deswegen habe
ich die Zwiebel Knoblauch Würfel
angebraten die Soße darin zubereitet und
jetzt denke ich mir gerade so okay jetzt
mache ich es auch auf dem Herd fertig
dafür brauche ich jetzt keinen Backofen
mehr aber wenn ihr nicht am Herd kochen
wollt dann könnt ihr das ganze auch
gerne als one Pot ofengericht machen
dann so wie es gesagt habe alles in die
Ofenform rein ab in den Backofen 20 bis
25 Minuten bei 180 Grad und fertig ich
habe jetzt hier meine fertige Soße die
ist auch schon abgeschmeckt es fehlt
kein Salz
perfekt und jetzt habe ich hier meinen
Lachs der ist auch echt schon richtig
gut aufgetaut sieht man ganz gut den
lege ich jetzt hier rein und dann lasse
ich das einfach fertig garen und was ich
jetzt hier nicht machen wollte ich mag
es einfach nicht wenn es daheim sein
nach Fisch riecht deswegen habe ich
jetzt auch den Lachs nicht angebraten
ihr könnt es aber auch gerne machen dann
bekommt er noch mal eine schöne Kruste
das würde ich dann ganz am Anfang machen
und wirklich den Lachs erst anbraten
dann aus der Pfanne rausnehmen und dann
eben die Soße zubereiten und wenn ihr
Lachs
anbratet an Brett wenn ihr Lachs
anbraten möchtet
dann am besten in einer beschichteten
Pfanne damit der Fisch eben nicht klebt
so
hier kommt jetzt der Deckel drauf und
dann kann der Lachs hier etwa 10 bis 15
Minuten schön durchziehen jetzt kann ich
hier auch schon mal den Herd anschalten
fürs Nudelwasser und dann ist alles
gleich fertig
aufgeräumt ist auch gleich
und dann sind wir gleich das Essen aber
dauert noch kurz die Nudeln müssen erst
noch rein
das Wasser kocht jetzt kann ich hier
Salz dazugeben für die Nudeln ihr dürft
die natürlich selber machen ihr könnt
uns aber nicht selber machen
Nudeln rein kochschutz drauf und dann
warten wir bis alles fertig ist
hervorragend
die Nudeln habe ich jetzt schon bereits
abgegossen ich hebe mir auch immer ein
bisschen was vom Nudelwasser auf damit
ich sie später falls sie dann doch
kleben einfach entkleben kann
und ich serviere jetzt alles hier in
einer Form weil ich finde schon dass es
immer auch wichtig ist dass alles was
auf den Tisch kommt auch hübsch aussieht
und manchmal sehr wenig schon den Töpfen
und Pfannen aber manchmal will ich auch
einfach in einer schönen Form haben
damit es eben gut aussieht deswegen
kommt jetzt hier alles rein und so würde
ich es dann eben auch auf den Tisch
servieren
[Musik]
dann kommt da noch etwas Basilikum dazu
und mit Parmesan servieren
Jutta magst du heute probieren ja klar
auf dem Tisch super und ich würde sagen
wir nehmen jetzt einfach den Teller
was machst du
[Musik]
es macht richtig was her gell
schön anrichtet ja
[Musik]
richtig lecker bitte dann Jutta darfst
du gerne probieren ja
[Musik]
bitte
so schön zart wieder jetzt ist
einfach lecker oder
richtig gut
und das ist auch was was die Kinder
gerne essen denn die lieben Lachs und
Nudeln
auf jeden Fall schnelles einfaches
Gericht ja für jeden Tag und auch
von den Kosten her relativ okay finde
ich ja kann man gerne mal Fisch essen
möchte also probiert das Rezept gerne
mal aus und einfach zu machen ja
so sieht's aus einfache Rezepte lieben
wir für den Alltag also probiert das
Rezept gerne mal aus wir setzen uns
gleich
das große
wir setzen uns gleich auch zur
Mittagspause raus in die Sonne
tatsächlich waren es auch noch Tomaten
aus meinem Garten denn wir haben noch
richtig viele Tomaten an den Sträuchern
und es sind so die letzten die wir
gerade noch verwerten die anderen wurden
schon eingekocht und ja ist immer lecker
mit Tomaten aus dem eigenen Garten
probiert es gern aus auf sallys-blog.de
findet ihr das Rezept und natürlich in
meiner App bis zum nächsten Mal Ciao
tschüss